day four of rejection therapy today
i am going to my local jewel and asking
if i can do an announcement
over the speaker i've been a loyal
customer for years
and i think it's time that i get
rewarded
for my loyalty
hi is there like a store manager i could
talk to
is kevin still here
is
thank you
yeah i had a question what's up i wanted
to know if i could make like an
announcement on the speakers
i've always wanted to and it's my life's
dream
what kind of announcement did you want
to make um i just want to say that jewel
is my favorite grocery store
you want to make it yeah
um okay
kind of an odd request but um
that's all you want to do yeah that's it
okay is that okay
sure um
let's make an announcement
so i said jules in favor of graphics
yeah
[Music]
what
attention jewel customers
i wanted to let you know that this is
the best grocery store
on the planet thank you
thank you
what is that i'm telling you you don't
do it like a scavenger hunt
or something no um it's called
um it's for my tic tac channel oh okay
so it's called like a hundred days of
rejection so you go and ask people
things every day hoping to get a note
here
[Music]
thanks
oh my god oh my god
i did not say yeah that's crazy
um
why do people keep saying yes to me
why
oh my god oh my god i'm sweating why
did they say yes to that why